[Musique]
c'est un concept de restaurant américain
des années 50 60 donc vous allez
retrouver chez nous tout l'univers
marinine monerau Elvis prley la musique
le cinéma on ouvre un nouveau restaurant
dans le centre commercial alpha Park le
6 décembre au clés
sousbois pour l'ouverture du restaurant
on recrute environ 30 personnes en
cuisine et en salle donc il y a peu près
tous les postes les postes d'encadrement
que ce soit chef de cuisine second chef
de partie mais également directeur ou
directrice adjoint direction leader et
mais aussi des serveurs bien entendu des
cuisiniers des commis sales ou des
commis de
cuisine vous pouvez encore postuler il
reste quelques postes en salle
essentiellement et on cherche uniquement
des CDI temps complet
39h plusieurs créneaux on va dire soit
sur inded soit avec le Pôle emploi soit
sur notre site inter internet
hisdiner.fr mais également en postulant
directement venant au restaurant ou sur
l'adresse mail
[Musique]
olisplaisir@asdor.fr